honey you like the person that was good
while every chain yeah I think it was 27
I was [ __ ] pumped cuz I twice him and
people watch this holy shoes is awesome
I mean listen I'm telling you there is a
complete ridiculous awful thought
process in our startup environment right
now like when you 98 followers on
Twitter 90 people night 8 human beings
want to hear your dumbest [ __ ] random
thoughts you know how thank believe me
and so I mean it like it's funny I could
thought about this that here asked this
question I was pumped because first of
all one thing you know like do you know
why I want to buy the New York Jets it's
a long journey right I love the journey
I don't like [ __ ] I don't wanna buy
stuff I'm gonna car all my friends I
don't want to test them [ __ ] test you
know what you know like I don't want
those things I I like the journey to 27
meant tomorrow I better get 49 right
like I'm the kind of guy who hates going
backwards you know but I fear going the
other way like I don't like winning a
lot I don't like where I'm at right now
and stuff you're right
I like wouldn't like I loved coming into
the agency world because nobody knew
what the hell I was right there like
well that's like you know like I love
I'm like good good sleep sleep mommy
[ __ ] you know that's who I am
I don't like this like oh you're good
and like you're great like I hate that
you know like I mean let me start over
I love it
I love I love the admiration I love the
engagement I love that it gives me an
opportunity to engage with people to see
people that I really I love I do love
that a boy do I really love the client
I love the climb and so none nobody give
a [ __ ] about me nothing about you and a
hat forget about that that's really a
year and a half and not a lot was going
on it was slow it wouldn't listen things
were tougher to get a viral at some
level so it wasn't in place Facebook was
kids and school evening you only Twitter
wasn't here yet right like you know yes
I could get like a blog mention them you
know but I wasn't good enough like I
think like I didn't get my pack right
that first time when I went outside and
tasted wine in the smell and like I was
like if this doesn't get me on dick I'm
gonna kill somebody and it did that not
but you know it was like the things like
that it was just extra teach it right
like you know obviously Kevin Rossum
alex albrecht were doing a bunch of
stuff for all the techies in the year on
diggnation I was trying to figure out
how to like get into that circle of
video bloggers that so I into the time
and by the way it was happening while my
business was starting to go sale for the
first time ever because the mic wasn't
paying attention calm anymore in a store
I was trying to build my brand so it
wasn't happening when I was 22 and had
nothing to really worry about other than
maybe you're sharing apartment and with
your friends and maybe can't go out as
many nights again mine was option for
those money and still like it took like
a stomach to like be like this is right
yep